[Music]
[Applause]
an old enemy has finally surfaced
one of my spies has linked the attacks
on our star destroyers with the new
republic starhawk project
a common factor is lyndon james
you knew james better than anyone
captain carol
if i had
i'd have destroyed him before he
betrayed us at foster haven
then this is your second chance
the rebels are keeping a low profile
take titan squadron hunt down this
starhawk and eliminate it gladly admiral
sloane
but if i may ask
there's a particular pilot i'd like to
requisition
[Music]
the treacherous slime taking our ships
good more than merrier
remember the last time you lost your
call the day i cut through a whole
squadron of rebels has saved your name
[Applause]
[Music]
your new ring mate has arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you're our new wingmate
welcome to titan squadron i'm varco gray
squadron leader
i think they're waiting for you in the
briefing room
better make a good first impression
welcome home pilot
it feels like a lifetime since foster
haven doesn't it
one fool betrays his squadron and loyal
officers like us are reassigned in
disgrace
i heard they sent you to the outer rim
i got the medams sector
protecting fuel shipments from petty
scoundrels and pirates
the kind of posting that used to end
careers
before endor
before
lyndon james reappeared
no doubt you've heard
admiral sloane has instructed me to hunt
that traitor down and end this project
star hawk
it seemed fitting that i bring you back
to help me destroy lyndon
your empire needs you pilot are you
willing
good
for now you will be flying as titan 3
let's get to work
one of our spies agent thorne has
discovered vital intelligence on project
starhawk
your mission is to extract her from an
orbital outpost above hosni and prime
your job is to secure the outpost for
our extraction team who will arrive
aboard the shuttle gladius
behind enemy lines you must be precise
and swift we have no room for error
titan
to gain access you'll have to eliminate
perimeter defenses
intelligence reports missile platforms
defending hosnian space
destroy them
the outpost itself is protected by turbo
laser cannons on all sides evade and
eliminate them all
when you've secured the area you will
escort the gladius to the outpost and
our extraction team will acquire agent
thorne
once thorn is secure reach your gozanti
cruisers and return to the overseer do
not lose our spy under any circumstances
that is all
i'm run a soul
no need to introduce yourself
i've already reviewed your service
record
it's been a long time since you were on
the front lines
in days past a mission like ours would
have been afforded every possible
resource
unfortunately
times are tight since endor
in one battle we lost our emperor and
gained a hundred warring factions
if only emperor palpatine hadn't
dissolved the imperial senate at least
then senators like my parents could have
maintained order after endor but no
not that i questioned the emperor's
decision of course but now that he's
gone we must look to the future
and reinstating the senate would help
subdue all of this infighting
we can talk later perhaps
now more than ever the empire needs
reliable soldiers like agent thorne
like you
unity is the only path to progress
i trust you are aligned with admiral
sloane's vision for the empire
we cannot afford to fracture
not after endor
this mission is a vital step towards
dismantling the rebellion
and they are a rebellion
don't be fooled by their new name
the new republic will fall just like the
last one
it's time for you to play your part
get to the hangar
ready your ship
you'll be the new pilot sergeant wait
chief mechanic and head of the hangar
crew don't see the appeal in flying
myself but i've been working on thai
since they rolled off the assembly line
your fight is in good hands
the overseer saw some action at pothole
in jail but it's had a complete
inspection and overhauled for this
mission admiral sloan's orders
and on my orders every tie in this hang
has been serviced and test flown tighten
half the rivets myself
we're ready
gotta say i don't know how you and titan
kobe are there
no shields or life support just hold
plating between you and space
it must build character never met a tie
pilot who backed down from any challenge
shields or not
i've prepared your starfighter to match
the latest imperial guidelines
but if you've got a preferred component
we'll need something customized i'll
take care of it just say the word
your tie fight is ready good flying
newcomer
welcome to titan
call me shen
before you ask
helmet stays on cockpit or not
too many hard landings
broken neck
five
six times
cybernetics keep me going
fight fall
get up
fight again
all for the empire
advice
don't annoy von wreck
good talk
another time
you're the new arrival
i'm javina vonreg
titan can always use another pilot so
long as you're good at killing rebels
we're going right into their territory
hosnian prime
we'll give those scum just a taste of
what it was like at endor
i was there you know
when the rebellion murdered our emperor
half my squad died trying to defend him
captain carol understands she doesn't
lecture me about justifiable force like
my other commanders
she knows all i need is a target
politics are for admirals
i keep it simple
always shoot to kill
mess with the squadron and you mess with
me
but do your job and i'll have your back
later
the tie fighter classic maneuverable
flexible
can't take much direct fire but that's
no problem for a skilled pilot
[Music]
your loadout however is not standard and
again
neither are any of titan squadron's
missions
i think you'll be happy with it
right
[Music]
my
[Applause]
squadron on me
imperial fighters divert course and
leave the system immediately or you will
be destroyed
how it's right
remember we must be swift and precise
they'll scramble fighters quickly
no doubt they'll reinforce from the
surface as well as the station
rebels
[Applause]
outer defenses
i'm on your way
missile defense system is activated
we can shoot down their salvos
nice
unless you have a death wish
keep it up
that's what i like to see
[Music]
[Applause]
enemy is locking on
good work
that's how it's done
titan watch they've reached our missile
defenses
scramble fighters take down those ties
i wish i could see the panic inside that
station right now
we should take out the shield generator
without it the turbo lasers are
vulnerable
[Music]
rebel starfighters inbound
watch your backs
we need a clear landing zone for our
extraction shuttle
evacuation transports get the cargo out
of here
i'm seeing a rebel transport ship
fleeing the outpost
and we won't let it escape eliminate the
rebel transport
[Applause]
so
pick it up
how dare you
rebel
three you got them all
you see it take it out
this side's clear attack what remains
keep it
up i want that god
i'm here let's go
the outpost is defenseless
titan this is
inbound for extraction
we read you gladius titan will
rendezvous with these coordinates
[Applause]
take it up
you're being hunted
[Applause]
i'm here impressive
i didn't need your help
[Applause]
pick it
up all over me
good shooting
information and ready
[Applause]
i'm in position
excellent work
joining your position
good riddance rebel scum
[Applause]
closing in on your titan squadron
we'll keep you safe gladius let's get
you to the outpost's landing platform
affirmative squadron leader
will be gone before the rebel fleet even
knows we were here
heads up squadron enemy a-wings are
deploying from the station
don't let them intercept our shuttle
take it out
that's the way
here i am
that's the last of the star fighters
we've reached the station initiating
extraction
shuttle has landed they're storming the
outpost
squadron we're on route to agent
thorne's location standby
be ready to retreat
why flee when we could blast the station
to dust
escaping with agent thorne as captain
carol's strategy
we gain nothing by destroying a single
outpost
[Music]
or enemy fighters inbound
they've come from the surface
only to die in space shoot them all down
[Applause]
they've locked off
i'm in position
i want that gone
[Applause]
you see it take it out
watch out enemies pursuing
takes care of that
i've had it under control
[Music]
you got them
taking damage
someone's tailing
joining up
they're trying to tell you
[Applause]
watch that missile
they're shooting at me
you're just making me angry
[Music]
pick it up
[Applause]
i want that god
show no mercy
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
your reputation precedes you
it's good to know my life is in capable
hands
we won't let you down agent thorne
titan squadron regroup with the gladius
we're clear of the station
cover our escape and escort us to the
jump point
affirmative agent
we have republic corvettes inbounds move
titan
ladies change course and keep each of
thorns safe
titan 3 take out those fighters
protect the shuttle at all costs
one more for me
[Applause]
they're sending more
uh
just keep moving
more
watch out
and my respect
[Music]
reach the carrier and load up
let's leave this wretched system
more rebel ships inbound
[Music]
you're officially part of the squadron
now
[Music]
you